eight four four two Oh for each number
to dial if you're on hold stay on hold
and sit back and enjoy this conversation
he's one of our favorite guests and he
is dynamite in the new job Apatow film
that is available on video on demand
right now the king of Staten Island and
I know this because I grew up seeing
guys like this guy portrayed by Bill
burr who's back here on the show the
very funny and talented wickedly
talented to use the John Travolta fillet
phrase uh bill burr how are you bill hey
what's going on dude you were phenomenal
in this movie bill you're phenomenal
well you're phenomenal for actually
talking honky on your show I was loving
listening to the greatest goalies I
would have throw in Grant Fuhr yeah Mike
Vernon in 1989 they can Calgary all the
way hey man
Montreal in the final Dominik Hasek
remember Dominick remember him Dominik
Hasek yeah they got screwed in 99 he was
in the creep they called it all year
because you're the biggest goal of the
year they don't call it but hockey does
that last year hmm
my beloved Bruins God got a taste for
their own medicine they think they
actually lost in the finals by a team
playing Bruins hockey but the NHL had
penalized that out of the game
so we showed up with an Olympic hockey
team like a finesse team and they
started taking liberties and we had no
answers and they weren't calling it they
ran our goalie for like four out of the
seven games and all the loot reaches and
and guide like that unless we replace
them with goal scorers so was that the
run that where we saw cam neely throw a
water bottle right in the in yet in the
management suite make any sense
so what hockey does never makes any
sense it's like they go okay we're going
in this direction so we go okay so they
penalized every team for playing the way
the Bruins always think that the way to
Blues played last year I love that
salafi but they just got rid of it
because they're trying to I don't know
be more mainstream I have no what I
don't know what
so everybody kinda showed up with
finesse team and then they showed up
playing like you know mid-90s hockey
punch everybody in the mouth and they
you know arguably beat like three seeds
that if they just played the Olympic
style I don't know if they'd be no but
I'm not trying to think the way cuz it's
very happy for st. Louis but but hockey
has a history of sort of calling stuff
you know for and all of a sudden the
playoffs come a big big big trick and
the NFL's done it - I mean I guess
they're very sport is going through a
bill burr here on the Rich Eisen show
again the king of Staten Island you play
a firefighter I'm from Staten Island I
think I've told you that before I was
born in Brooklyn but raised in Staten
Island for some six months on it's a
great movie man you're great in it and I
guess the only way to describe it is
this Wilford Brimley type mustache that
you're rocking did it take for you to
grow that one out bill that is not that
is natural right that is naturally grown
well I already had a beard pretty close
I got Don Johnson I keep it closed I try
to keep it sexy for the ladies and then
some the beginning of April wheel they
were like all right what are we gonna do
you're gonna grow your hair out on top
and I was like I don't know if I want to
do that I kind of think it's cool bald
firefighter kind of look cool so he said
I just let your beard go and I said all
right cool so I just let it go so it was
like maybe like just shot short at two
months and yeah I had like this clean
shaven head with this scraggly beard I
look like a like I was a hipster you
know it's gonna say art isn't something
you know scream or something and then
they just started trimming it it was
really the hair and makeup people that
did it impaired people I guess you lose
so they just saw it all right and I was
like I was thinking you know the whole
thing what I learned on it on this on
the shoot which you can't have a beard
as a firefighter because you'll it'll
ruin the seal if you have to have that
you wearing a mask shirt you're allowed
to have a mustache so I wanted it to be
a little you know just because the guy's
gonna come in and disrupt his lights
like everything from like his mustache
everything that he did should have been
offensive
well Pete Davidson you're fern - you see
he's a plays a misguided mixed-up
kid because his father was a firefighter
died when he was seven and Pete
Davidson's real-life dad died on 9/11
and you're there
you know looing his mother played by
Marissa Tomei who again reminded me of
everyone I grew up with and there's a
part in this film bill where you invite
Pete Davidson's character to a Yankee
game and you say he thought you meant
the actual Yankees but no the Staten
Island Yankees which is a real thing
they have a minor league stadium that
overlooks downtown Manhattan it's
amazing what the best view other than
the Pittsburgh Pirates I would say it's
well notice it's got to be the best view
of any minor league stadium no doubt
looking at Manhattan no doubt about and
but there's a line in it where you say
you're really a Red Sox fan but you go
to these games because you're a baseball
fan
did you add live that bill did you
insist that you at least had to put that
in there for yourself personally no no I
think that they were covering for my I
still have a little bit of the box and I
mean I found I mean I don't literally go
pack the cadu it was going on or
whatever I don't do that but I
definitely the way I talk I think or I
think maybe they thought I was known to
well that just would have stuck out to
people cuz okay I've just talked about
it so much but no that was not my idea
I just thought again that it was like
you went to Apatow and said look man
there's enough for this Yankee stuff I
just can't have it
I gotta at least say I'm a Red Sox fan I
thought this was a demand that you had
bill no you know being a Judd Apatow
movie I've been a fan of his movies for
a long time and I love that you
mentioned how Marisa Tomei reminded you
of every yes you know women how great
was she I think people just take for
granted that she's just gonna
automatically be awesome she was
incredible the second thing she put
those glasses on it was she just
disappeared and just became you know
Scott's mom Margy was she was amazing
and arguably the best I've ever I've
worked a lot of great people she was
incredible she's I mean you could say in
a way she's prepared for it I mean
Monalisa vetoes seems straight out of
Staten Island - all those years ago and
wanted my cousin Vinnie
that's I grew up with a lot of a lot of
Mona Lisa vetoes as well
bill burr here on the Rich Eisen show
okay bill prior to you joining this
program about a half an hour ago
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers put out
photographs of Tom Brady wearing his
Buccaneer uniform for the very first
time you know I just wanted you to have
a frame of reference you know at the
very lean up and you've always been a
caring guy it's a deserved reputation
you have they think you'll make sure
everybody is taken care of so I
appreciate that rich so I mean what do
you think bill what do you think well
you know as an older guy myself they
could have done him a little better with
those with some of the lighting on those
but I look yeah I would love for him to
still be with the Patriots but like
Keith literally put the franchise on his
back him and Belichick and Robert Kraft
like made us an actual like one of the
top franchises in the history of the NFL
now and before they all came along I
mean we were a joke you know Chuck
Fairbanks very underrated though look at
this 1974 Draft is incredible
or 73 I think was a 73 74 was the
Steelers had a great draft but but you
know he put us on the map I mean it's
the guy he was six if he just won one we
would have named a street after him he
won 63 feet it twice in the NFL that
never happens
he went to we went to nine Super Bowls I
mean all of a sudden like we became
during his time that we became the team
that went to the most Super Bowls like
that all of a sudden we came into the
Dallas Cowboys 49ers stratosphere which
just seemed untouchable when I was
growing up when we had Paul Revere on
the side of our helmet or whatever the
hell like I was supposed to be country
it's weird that the announcement
happened during the pandemic so
everything kind of goes as far as the
sports world just got knocked down in
order of importance but now that they're
showing that
as much as you know I'm bummed out that
he's not with us anymore there's two
things that make me happy one football
is coming back
that makes me psyched and then two you
know there's a lot of great quarterbacks
throughout history finished on another
team and never won a championship so if
he gets number seven as far as
modern-day athlete he'll have one more
than Jordan and trying to think if
anybody else got six no maybe it was
another basketball player that kind of
jumped around had a few give me a Robert
Horry Robert Horry
I think Robert Horry yeah convinced five
or six right could be five yeah so but
what do you think of the fact though
that you know you and I had spoken since
Brady did leave we haven't just seen him
in the in the pewter and then the
all-black uniform and then he's in they
didn't put him in the end they in the in
the old popsicle creamsicle uniform
which is too damn bad because that's the
one I think that would be most difficult
for you to handle but what about the
fact that Gronk
we went on such a run yes and I say we
as a sports fan because we when we lost
I also took all that stuff people didn't
chant 1918 at the Red Sox they chanted
it at me all right
no it is a weight thing here understood
I love that you guys are so excited that
something bad finally happened that like
this is all you have to grasp on through
is that at the end of his career
okay he's on like another team like
that's the best yet after all these
years of Jim Irsay
okay Indianapolis Colts bitch-ass
organization that could never take a lot
and and the fact that Brady and
Belichick was beaten all your asses so
bad across the league that you guys
actually co-signed on the owner of a
losing team conducting his own
independent investigation that was
laughs : with laughed out of court the
judge actually got mad for them wasting
their time and then the suspension was
reversed and then the NFL just goes well
are we a corporation and they go yes
since a corporation has the right to
suspend an employee and they go yeah and
that was the loophole that they
suspended them on and yet still paid and
treated and by the way that holds stupid
deflategate that wasn't even a scientist
that conducted it found the deflated
balls on the cold side too which was
completely ignored ESPN then did a study
showed a deflated ball actually got
there a half a second later or whatever
which debunked the whole thing they took
that down from their website so I want
to see now is he wins in Tampa I want to
see if Jim Irsay goes after him and all
these blood hurt people around the NFL
for all these years when you go on the
NFL Network and you see bills Bill
Parcells telling stories about Bill
Walsh pretending his headset went out
and he already called his whole first
half of plays during a playoff game and
that's that steps laid off as
gamesmanship something somebody be like
you know I heard that they actually had
a go throw the first down marker
and they were listening and all of that
crap it's like the whole league when
Isaiah Thomas for the last 20 years it
was embarrassing okay listen you think
Eli Manning's one of my favorite
quarterbacks ever and he broke my heart
twice the guy is a beast and in the
bigger the game was the bigger he played
now I can say that why can't Jim Irsay
the Colts ever just give this guy and do
and I'm going to tell you it's not going
to age well like rollerblading
I love the fact that I showed you these
photographs and you went when I first
asked you for a reaction you went
highbrow you and highbrow you went you
know what Brady gave us a high don't try
to make a ball
to make a ball and strike that was
outside ball one on your club I have no
problem he is an adult that guy so many
times deferred money down the road so we
could have a better team in win
championship he deserves to get paid he
deserves to play in a state that has no
state tax good for him all right that's
what I'm saying but I'm going back to
how some weasel in Indianapolis okay
who's sitting around by Tiny Tim's
ukulele is somehow judging what a guy's
doing on the football field and then you
guys in the media listen to it yes you
guys me you just painted me with the
very same brush to do is mention
popsicle uniforms and grunts playing
with Brady and then this whole thing
started you didn't know you didn't see
that's what you fans above it be sing
god bless them I love that grunts of the
year off they destroyed his knees I own
his leg I hope that that guy doesn't get
hurt okay I've got what I need to do I
like all the everything's doing sitting
the Red Sox win a World Series okay say
one for I'm good
we won six we want a fairly cup and we
would we would like a soccer
championship hmm I'm fine with that my
thing about it is is that you weasel in
the media cushion handle that he had
movie star good looks he had a
supermodel girlfriend and when it came
down when you need it to deliver he
always did and what it did was reminded
all you oughta shake sports writers how
many times you didn't get picked in gym
class when you went after and you went
after you keep trying to paint it then
oh my god he's all butthurt that he went
to Tampa I'm not excited about that but
it's his career okay but I'm also still
I want to know now if he wins in Tampa
yeah what are you guys going to come up
with it has to do with the oranges
nothing down there no no no I did
gradients do I always give Brady's do
I'm with you I just love seeing just
again welcoming the Patriots fans to the
rest of the fan bases in the NFL
the last 20 years that you enjoyed that
magic carpet ride now everybody's back
now it's kind of even even playing field
right now that's all that's all that's a
terrible point because I'm a 52 year old
man I was there sent Chuck there but
that's true you did go you did go Chuck
that's by the way and I'm walking down
Main Street and I'm supposed to have
balloons dropped on me and you're
popping all of them right now because
Teddy by the way the horses and cold I
am different by the F is for Fairbanks
literally not even hold up in a court of
law bill in the break he was like hey
can you just text me those Brady photos
so I can send them was your fellow who
is your fellow New England man here he's
on yourself and it was the 73 draft John
Hannah and the first round hall-of-famer
greatest guard of all time yes Gerald
singly they got all kinds of people then
the break from Tim Fox in 77 he built an
amazing team which by the way in 76
which was wide open fearless according
to Joe bartnik had that best team ever
but flyer and Franco Harris both got
hurt and that's why the Raiders were
finally able to get past and the New
England Patriots went into open had the
Raiders beat and then there was a bein
very borderline roughing the passer call
that took the ball only down the goal
line you know Ken Stabler he's not going
to blow it down there and then they beat
it so the whole top rule thing was a
payback for that and then not to mention
this Huck rule that's not the first time
they called for a fan was called it was
called against the Patriots during it
just game so there you go these are the
facts at all but you want to or like I
said you can sit around with a guy with
tiny kids ukulele and you can feel
better
gym class I mean if that's what you want
to do or you can get somebody to do like
I do with you I'm in bill burr the king
of Staten Island available now on demand
and season four of the Netflix animated
series epitome iord on Friday last week
bill as the creator and star of that
series you are the man bill I really
appreciate it thanks for the call you
take care of yourself me too you take
care that's perfect I got you got ad
bill a bar on twitter at wilfred burr on
instagram the one the only that's what
we call a good spot so in retrospect
good idea to forward him the photograph
your intention he had six championships
for a sambar I'm not gonna stand in its
way and whatever and then I mentioned
the popsicle uniforms and grant played
and then oh it was on like the
proverbial Donkey Kong
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here